we learned the threat of China through
the pandemic and if that is just the
beginning literally it's just the
beginning we have no idea what they're
having what's coming for us afterwards
and the fact that we don't like hold the
channel accountable what was happening
with the pandemic right now that's
what's disturbing to me imagine this was
the job of America because this pandemic
to the world how they're going to
condemn us
so much to our grave and nobody
condemned China because they are all
making money out of this evil regime so
it's a I think that's a thing just we
continue to see that in America and
everywhere these people try to make the
money for themselves and don't do the
right thing